all the machines in this arcade are
homemade there's something magical about
all this
as a child i found that making things
that made people laugh was satisfying
and seemed more pointed in doing that
than making useful machines
[Music]
i'm tim hunkin and i'm a cartoonist and
engineer
i have two arcades one on the coast and
a pier and this one in central london
called novelty automation
in total i suppose i made about 50
machines
not many people have that as their
ambition in life but yeah it suits me
this is petal meat you spin the wheel
and you find if the land ends up sitting
with you on the sofa or being carved for
dinner
it was a hobby that got out of control
this is auto frisk you stand in front
here the gloves inflate
and then they back you down
britain's got a great history of satire
and i suppose i'm not really
particularly political myself but
i think it's healthy for little people
to poke fun at the rich and powerful you
fly this little drone
uh around this beverly hills mansion and
see all the stars inside and your
paparazzi you have to try and take the
photos to fill up the cover of the
magazine we are all under arrest
i get my ideas from lots of places it's
partly things happening in my life
partly things happening in the news
and partly from old arcade machines and
mechanisms this is test your nerve you
have to put your hand inside the cage
with the mad dog for as long as you dare
to do something like this you have to
enjoy the process of making things i
spent most of my life solving
conventional engineering problems rather
than thinking up the jokes
this is the chiropodist you have to take
off your shoe for this one you put your
foot in the treatment bay down the
bottom
and it feels really weird seeing people
enjoying using the machines keeps me at
it and also because they take money it
provides the income to let me keep at it
so to me it's a pretty perfect system it
sure beats working good morning
i've never planned my career or anything
about my life it's just occasionally a
sort of opportunity comes up and then i
go for it
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
remember zoltar the fortune teller from
the movie big
the mysterious machine turned a young
boy's wish into reality
in real life there are hundreds of
zoltar's all over the country and you
can trace them all back to this guy
my name is olaf stanton and i make
zoltar
[Music]
olaf runs characters unlimited a company
that makes animated talking characters
and one of those machines is the fortune
teller the fortune tower is probably one
of the oldest games there is it's been
around since the turn of the century
perhaps the most famous one is zoltar
but just to be clear they didn't make
the one from the movie big the zoltar in
the movie big was basically a movie prop
it was never made to be a manufactured
game our zoltar has the talking come let
zoltar tell you more and eye movement
and head turning and spits out a card at
the end of the conversation and gives
you some good words of advice
every zoltar machine is custom-made
first thing we do is get the cabinet
started then we'll cast the head out of
our latex material
we put the eyeballs in we paint the head
then it goes to our wig department
zoltar's goatee is put on
the teeth are put in which are actually
my teeth wait they're your teeth yes
they're actually my teeth i actually
made a mold on my teeth so every zoltar
you see out there has my teeth in them
and then we put all the components in
that make the card come out and make a
talk and give the different messages
and then zoltar is ready to go
[Music]
all those old tars the starve our
fortune terror line he's not the only
fortune tower that we make we have papi
we have the old pirate
and those fortunes
that's all off too
we try to make all of our fortunes on
the lighter side good words of wisdom
and advice i think one of my favorite is
sometimes it's better to say too little
than to say too much and regret it later
there's a lot of good words of wisdom
that come out of zoltar i think people
just like to see something that they can
relate to and say oh yeah how did you
know that that's so cool it really does
bring out the child in all of us to see
your fortune on a card
well unless of course you're talking
about tom hanks in the movie big because
he gets well you know
big
in the 80s when lots of people were
playing arcade games like pac-man donkey
kong and frogger this is what they were
playing in soviet russia
[Music]
that's alexander he runs the museum of
soviet arcade machines in st petersburg
russia
[Music]
[Music]
the point of the games was training for
the soviet army building skills like
reasoning and eye coordination and
marksmanship
seriousness
all the soviet arcade games were built
in military factories using leftover
parts from weapons refrigerators
calculators and other items
[Music]
[Music]
i'm billy mitchell video game player of
the century
i did the world's first perfect score on
pac-man 333
360.
it's exhausting to just say it
i began in the competitive world of
pinball
it moved to donkey kong
but the greatest level of competition at
the moment was pac-man
if i was going to be the best i had to
be the best at the game that was
everywhere so in 1999 i sent out a press
release i was as cocky as could be they
said there's been 10 billion games
played how are you going to do it i says
because i'm billy mitchell
you start off on the first board but on
board 21 that's where it reaches maximum
difficulty you have to navigate all the
way to board 255
doing the same repetitive thing you
can't miss a dot a prize a blue man you
can't die once
you can't lose focus you've got to stay
with it all the way there four to five
hours
you have to take a corner down to one
sixtieth of a second
in order to create perfect timing and
keep your eye right here right here
you have to do that over 29 thousand
times
without making any mistakes and dying
you play 255 boards on 256 there's
enough memory left in the game for the
left half of the board and not the right
half
the right half is filled with computer
garble anything and everything that is
not packed in different walls different
dots
that's what a perfect score is
the moment that score went up there
i thought wow i achieved perfection
you get to the end there's nothing to do
but die there was nothing saying
congratulations there was nothing saying
the end game over nothing the designer
of pac-man
not only did he never think anyone would
get to the end he didn't know where the
end was
he didn't know at what point the game
would run out of memory everything to
him is completely baffling they never
saw the split screen until i sent it to
them
messiah nakamoto who's the godfather of
video games
he crowned me video game player of the
century for that and all the previous
achievements
it doesn't get any higher than that
[Music]